how's it going anime fans let me start
by asking you a question what types of
moments are your favorite moments in
anime is it the confession scene the
finisher sequences and fights personally
i love few things more than epic
entrances those entrances do a lot in
giving your viewers a strong first
impression in the case of a new
character or giving them their much
awaited and glorious return if they're a
powerful mental character gone missing
even our protagonists benefit from this
as the best entrances come with surefire
signs of successful character
development so for today's list i'll be
going through 10 of the best entrances
in action anime in my opinion but before
anything i'd like you to subscribe to
the channel in order to get the latest
updates on what i have in store for you
with that out of the way let's get
started
the great anime entrance for a new
character should serve as an
establishing moment of how badass he is
coming in with glorious music and a down
titan for the save levi surely made an
impact when he entered the scene this
scene has it all and as far as attack on
titan's concerned i couldn't have asked
for a better dynamic entry it
establishes what a strong character levi
is shows us what his role is in the
chain of command and gives us a glimpse
of his analytical personality the titan
slaying that follows is just the cherry
on top seeing humanity's strongest
soldier in action like that is a sight
to behold no wonder you got fangirls
getting wet over him almost a decade
later
uh
[Music]
helsing has a whole array of badass
moments the fight scenes and the
showcase of alucard's broken powers
probably deserve a video of their own
but it has its fair share of epic
entrances as well in terms of entrances
this one gets extra points for the build
up you see alucard immediately but he's
surrounded by relative silence you just
see the guy from afar but the way it's
presented you know something big is
gonna go down then the music hits and he
makes an adrenaline pumping jump into
the burning city right in the middle of
the tension field stare down between two
forces on a collision course not
everyone but the most badass of
characters could do that and alukar did
it with style you can see the whole
thing on youtube so seriously just check
it out
need a way to show how godly a character
is let hideo she teach you this scene
here encapsulates the things that we can
see from sengoku basada and just how
powerful hideyoshi is how about punching
an entire mountain into existence by
parting the sea make water evaporate
with sheer force yep you got that right
it's really amazing how sengoku basara
made hideyoshi look like a god among
mortals i mean how can you even compare
you've got to admit though i was caught
off guard a bit here i know that this is
anime and that we'll be seeing such
feats like these however to see
something as wild as this in sengoku
basara was a real treat the most amazing
fact about this is that hideyoshi's not
even someone who uses weapons imagine
doing all of that with just your fists
wow
[Music]
the eclipse is by far one of berserk's
darkest moments we have the good guys in
one hell of a bind godzing kaskar would
have suffered a fate worse than death
had skull knight not intervened after
what felt like forever skull knight had
finally fought his way through zord and
makes his big entrance seeing guts and
kaska in the state that they're in made
the wait much longer but the payoff of
seeing skull knight finally make his
appearance became a lot greater as a
result i know many of you aren't fans of
cgi however it doesn't make this moment
any less awesome skull knight comes in
and pretty much powers his way through
the demonic hordes just to rescue guts
and kaska it's a glorious and desperate
charge and i really got caught in the
moment seeing it for the first time
speaking of entrances and saving you
from all the pesky region locks is the
sponsor of this video expressvpn i mean
come on for all the talk of anime
becoming more and more available the
internet and regional licensing still
find a way to screw us over don't they
so having a vpn connection will help you
with unblocking all the exciting content
which may otherwise be blocked in your
regional country i've tried a lot of vpn
services before but none of them provide
the same level of quality that
expressvpn does for its cheap
subscription price you get some
top-notch quality service and the
fastest speeds available for any vpn
software in town once you boot the
program up just pick your server and
connect it really is as simple as that
now movies like your name and spirited
away are just a click away here let me
help you out by giving you three months
free and all you have to do is click the
link below or just go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube say goodbye to all those
problems with some quick clicks and
start enjoying the internet to the
fullest
at number five we'll be taking a look at
sinbad's entrance
[Music]
saying simbad's entrance can be quite
confusing when it comes to magi after
all he's had his fair share of dynamic
entries and goosebump inducing
appearances among all of them i'd give
top recognition to the one in the
magnostat arc in a long drawn-out fight
they've seen pretty much all of the name
characters of relevance popping a united
effort against the medium it's simbad's
appearance that turns the tides of the
battle i still remember seeing his grand
entrance as he strikes the boss monster
with his jinn's lightning attacks and he
doesn't come alone along with him are
the strongest fighters of numerous
countries under the seven seas alliance
as well as morgiana and yunnan it's such
an epic moment with the episode being
capped off by his epic speech about
defeating a god
[Music]
[Applause]
number four is naruto's heroic entrance
in the pain arc
[Music]
destruction and despair lay in front of
payne's gonohi invasion we knew that the
guy was capable of something after his
victory over jiraiya but the ark really
drove on the sheer destructive power
that pain has in him the pain invasion
arc saw a lot of fallen heroes and a lot
of hopelessness for every ray of hope
that the hero see payne does something
to easily snuff it out it seems that all
is lost until he comes back coming in
with toads and doing a gynax pose we see
naruto in his new form having mastered
the secrets of sage mode he makes his
long-awaited return as the proud figure
that looks to put pain in his place it's
a complete contrast to the kid that we
grew up loving the underdog and the
outcast has finally become konoha's
long-awaited savior it's the culmination
of the underdog story that we've been
seeing from the very beginning
as we start off our top three we begin
with ichigo's entrance in karakura town
[Music]
it's been a long time coming for the
fated battle between ichigo and aizen
and nothing less than a spectacular
entrance would have sufficed good thing
the bleach anime got it down right one
of the most awesome moments in the fake
karakura town arc just became 10 times
more awesome when seen in anime form
coming in with a metal remix of his
theme the now long head ichigo prepares
to battle aizen from the onset you can
tell there's a lot that's happened ever
since the last time we saw our
protagonist gone was the hesitant teen
who showed signs of wavering resolve
instead we have the eyes of a man who's
grown to surpass his limits in such a
short space of time amazing entrance to
proceed the ass kicking that follows
we have the dragon dive scene from
hunter hunter
i've already sung praises for the kimira
antarctic several times but for all the
high praises that i've ever given it
never have i once mentioned one of the
epic moments early on in the ark until
now the palace invasion begins with a
bang and that's an understatement the
setup and the build up for the scene is
just amazing and we're greeted by the
site of thousands of aura shards
reigning into the palace to open the
chain of events it's the confusion and
the sheer destructive capabilities of
the shards that help facilitate the
mission and the locating of the ant king
while one could wonder why they went
with such a dynamic entry in what was
supposedly a stealth mission i'd say
that dragon dive served its purpose well
the confusion made locating merowim
easier and i assumed that it was
designed to brush all the weak and
suicide with its power
for anyone who's watched one piece you
all know that shanks is due for one of
the classic moments like this one it
helps that kobe set everything up with
his epic speech having enough of the
fighting the cowardly kobe finally steps
up and puts himself in the line of fire
in order to put an end to it all
unfortunately the forces at work
wouldn't have it and he would have found
himself yet another casualty if not for
this grand entrance stopping an attack
with his sword is cool enough but doing
it against akainu epic stuff but that's
expected from someone with the stature
of the likes of shanks this is a moment
that sent chills down my spine and i'm
sure that a lot of one piece fans felt
exactly the same way to think that this
is one of the most pivotal moments as
well because if it wasn't for this epic
entrance luffy probably wouldn't have
made it out alive thanks a lot shanks
not for only saving the main character
but for giving us one of the best
moments in one piece's storied history
[Music]
and with that we end this list how about
you guys what's your personal top 10
list of epic anime entrances looking
like please share it down in the comment
section below and let's see what you've
got now before leaving please leave a
like and if you enjoyed the content and
want to get up to date with the latest
news on vinnie tube hit that sweet
subscribe button and ring the bell don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video expressvpn bypass all those pesky
region locks and even browse sites not
available in your region with the ever
trustee expressvpn now i'll be seeing
you on the next list and until then
goodbye
[Music]
you